hey guys I want to talk about fruit on a ketogenic
diet a lot of questions come up with that the
answer is no okay let me explain one it has too
much sugar even an apple has 19 grams of sugar
that's a medium Apple they even came up with
something called a Honey Crisp which is only
20 years old and they modified it to the point
where it has tremendous amounts of fructose if
you consume that Apple it's incredibly sweet
versus apples the original Apple which is kind
of very tart pineapples are very very very
sweet wild strawberries are not very sweet
while blueberries are not very sweet compared
to the ones you buy at the store and you never
ever ever want to consume fruit juices why
because the fiber it is attached is bound to
the phytonutrients so you get rid of the fiber
you're getting rid of a lot of the nutrients
Plus this juice is pasteurized it's cooked
so anything that potentially could be left
is pretty much killed especially the enzymes
in that future so you're basically getting
a concentrated concentrated fructose sugar a
lot of times they add corn syrup to it right
so you don't want to give your kids the fruit
juice you can give your kids fruit because your
metabolism is there and it can burn up pretty
fast just as an adult I wouldn't consume much
fruit especially for trying to lose weight but
you can I recommend berries that's fine if it's
like in small amounts one half cup to one cup
of berries per day but I like to put it in the
kale shake and I think that's totally fine now
fructose itself just so you know the sugar
fructose it can lead to insulin resistance it can
lead to a fatty liver and it can spike your blood
sugars even more than glucose okay alright
thanks for watching hey you probably already
subscribed but if you haven't press this little
button down below and I will keep you updated